uh over the last five or i guess now
we're on day
really oh wow today's actually the the
beginning of day
seven of the biden presidency we have
seen a dramatic change in what press
briefings
look like kaylee mcinanny who was
trump's press secretary was replaced
with jen sackey who is joe biden's press
secretary
and for the most part she answers the
questions that are asked she's still a
press secretary when it's not
advantageous to answer she won't but
we're actually getting valuable
information about what's going on with
joe biden now
one of the additional characters that
has sort of come to prominence
uh during the gen saki era is
the son of fox and friends anchor steve
ducey
named peter ducey peter ducey is steve
ducey's son
and he i guess is now part of the white
house press corps
and he has made it a habit to ask the
most
uh aggressive question he can and
good for him except that it's not good
journalism they're just sort of really
dumb gotcha type questions
and hilariously gen saki actually called
peter ducey steve ducey a couple of
times
so this is like a whole little
subculture thing that's developing in
the white house press briefings and i
want to look at some clips with you it
really does seem as though peter ducey
is trying to make himself known
as the tough guy who's willing to hold
gen saki accountable
except it just implodes hilariously
every time
here is one uh clip from when dr fauci
joined jen sackey last week at her first
or second press briefing
and uh peter ducey asked dr fauci about
rumors that amazon was now offering to
get involved
with covid19 and right-wingers say it's
bias
amazon refused to help trump now they
want to help joe biden in order to make
him look good
here is dr fauci asked about that by
peter ducey
yeah how helpful would it have been if
amazon
got involved with the federal response
to
copen 19 before biden
took office and do you know about any
plans or discussions
ahead of yesterday no i don't think i
could answer that
question i'd be waving my hands about
that sorry
well you know one of the new things in
this administration is if you don't know
the answer
don't guess just say you don't know the
answer yeah
yes now of course this has nothing to do
with dr
fauci peter ducey is i get it peter
ducey is implying
amazon has political motivations for not
helping
trump and offering to help biden that's
if it's true that amazon didn't offer to
help trump
i don't know we don't know the answer to
that but
the questions about amazon's involvement
during a prior administration
either need to go from to someone from
that administration
who was working on supplying logistics
which dr fauci was not
or to amazon the idea that that's a
question for dr fauci is hilarious and
peter ducey tried the same thing with
jen sackey the white house press
secretary
did the transition officials know before
yesterday that amazon wanted to get
involved in such a meaningful way
not that i'm aware of i'm happy to check
i mean when the reporting came out
i asked the question and i think uh
internally and
you know what was conveyed to me and i
don't think we discussed this yesterday
was that
we've had a lot of outreach um some
privately some publicly from a range of
businesses and private sector entities
and we certainly welcome
that and uh we'll be considering all of
those offers and what makes the most
sense in our
uh plans and proposals so because there
are some trump officials saying they
were never offered help from amazon and
so they're
essentially saying they think this was a
political call for amazon to wait
while lives were hanging the balance but
you're saying that
it's not the case i'm not aware of the
timeline of when amazon reached out that
sounds like a question for amazon to me
and that's exactly right did they reach
out to the trump administration i don't
know ask the trump administration
or ask amazon it's not really a question
for joe biden
why are they interested now what that's
a question for amazon it's not a
question for dr fauci
or for jen sackey then he goes to
isn't it divisive that there will be
impeachment
i'm sorry i told you i was gonna ask you
i just skipped over here go ahead i'll
take it now
uh so if president biden wants a
theme of his presidency to be unifying
the country does he think
that nancy pelosi and chuck schumer
should drop a potentially
divisive senate impeachment trial the
answer
should be the same every single time
joe biden will play no role whatsoever
in the impeachment trial he is not going
to try to get anyone in the senate
to do anything he is not going to try to
influence anyone in the senate
not to do anything joe biden was not in
the senate
when the house voted on impeachment joe
biden is not in the senate now
it would be inappropriate for joe biden
to exert any influence one way or the
other
he will remain totally out of it that is
the exact right answer and that's the
answer that should be given every single
time
peter ducey then also asked why didn't
joe biden wear a mask
on quote federal lands during the
inauguration
at the lincoln memorial go ahead why
weren't
president biden and all members of the
biden family matt
at all times on federal lands last night
if he signed
an executive order that mandates masks
on federal
lands at all times as the inaugural
memorial yes and of course they
basically
were wearing masks most of the time
masks did come off at one point
for some photographs it was just biden's
family together
probably a bad look but the idea that
this
is a gotcha question when the trump
administration's mis handling of the
virus
led to probably more than 100 000
unnecessary deaths
it's just ridiculous here is peter ducey
trying to call out joe biden
for putting in place travel restrictions
now
after previously calling donald trump's
travel restrictions xenophobic
and just one more about the announcement
you made off the top about the travel
restrictions
when president trump was imposing travel
restrictions in march
specifically on china then candidate
biden called it xenophobic and
fear-mongering
so now president biden is putting travel
restrictions on
people coming in from other countries
what words we use
to describe that now this is just not
true this has been repeated ad nauseam
biden said it was xenophobic he said the
travel restrictions were xenophobic
the truth is that biden supported covet
travel restrictions
and he called trump xenophobic
but not for the covid travel
restrictions this is one of those where
you
if you repeat it enough times it sort of
becomes true but
joe biden didn't say the covid
restrictions were xenophobic
he supported them and he also said that
donald trump was xenophobic
for other reasons yesterday joe biden
interestingly deliberately picking peter
ducey
knowing that ducey asks him sandbagging
questions check this out
uh ducey sort of asks a weird question
about shutting down the virus and joe
biden handles it perfectly well
now wait wait wait i know he always asks
me tough questions
and he always has an edge to them but i
like him anyway so go ahead and ask
the answer to ask the question thank you
mr president uh
so you just said that you think within
three weeks or so
we'll be at the point where there are a
million vaccines
per day but it seems like i think we'll
get there before that
i said i hope i misspoke i hope we'll be
able to increase
as we go around to get to the million
five a day that's my ex
my hope and then my the follow-up to
that would be i
now that you're a president and you're
saying there's nothing we can do
to change the trajectory of the pandemic
in the next
several months what happened to two
months ago when you
were talking declaratively about i am
going to shut down
the virus i'm going to shut down the
virus but not i never said i'd do it in
two months i said it took a long time to
get here
it's going to take a long time to beat
it and so we have millions of people out
there who are
who have the virus we're just for the
first day i think correct me if i'm
wrong i've been doing
other things this morning speaking with
foreign leaders but one of the things i
think this is one of the first days that
the numbers actually come down the
number of deaths
and the number on a daily basis and the
number of hospitalizations etc
it's going to take time it's going to
take a heck of a lot of time
and we still have as dr fauci constantly
points out
it's one thing when we have mass
how can i say it politely mass disregard
of the warnings about
not wearing masks and wearing masks and
and social distancing
and failure to social distance and
people getting together on
holidays in ways that weren't
recommended etc
we see first thing that happens is we
see
the uh the number of infections go up
then you see the hospitalizations go up
then you see the deaths go up
so remember that as reported yesterday
69 percent of the country
approves of joe biden's week one
handling of the pandemic
but regardless joe biden not phased
not thrown off by uh peter ducey there
and i think this is how ducey is going
to try to become more well-known
during this presidency i think that the
oan reporter i think it's oan chanel
ryan
also tried to become known for asking
certain types of questions during the
trump administration the problem was
she was uh very very bad oh where's that
noise coming i
apologize for that she was very very bad
at asking the questions
and so she never really became uh super
well known
uh ducey seems better at least at
formulating the questions and he may
very well
end up uh be becoming relatively known
for
dropping tough questions on gen saki and
joe biden but so far
the questions are all quite dumb if one
of your goals for the new year
is cutting back on carbs or sugar
check out our sponsor monk pack
monk pack keto nut and seed bars
our delicious sweet snacks with less
than one gram of sugar
only two to three grams of net carbs and
just about 150 calories perfect for a
keto or low carb diet or just about
anyone who wants to eat
better by cutting back on sugar i love
the monk pack
keto nut and seed bars because they're
really just a perfect balance of sweet
and salty
soft and chewy with a nice crunch from
the nuts and seeds
flavors include sea salt dark chocolate
pecan almond and peanut butter dark
chocolate my personal favorite and
they'll give you
all of your money back if you don't love
it go shop for monk pack
keto nut and seed bars at monkpack.com
the link is down below and they'll give
you 20 off when you use the coupon code
pacman